I've stayed silent on Eugenia Cooney for
years now and that's mainly because I
have like a general policy that I don't
talk about people's bodies I only
address the potentially problematic
behaviors that they share and promote
and Eugenia specifically is a really
interesting case because you know even
though her body is very likely
triggering for a lot of people as
evidenced by a lot of her comment
sections she doesn't explicitly promote
specific problematic behaviors even if
to so many people it's implied but you
know I thought about this case a lot and
again I'm not going to pile onto her as
so many on the internet have I am
however just really ashamed of us all as
a society we have really really let this
girl down this video has 64 million
views and 2 million likes two million
likes there are two million people up
regulating the social media algorithms
that get this girl more engagement more
viewership more fans Etc